which kardashian sister is the most  attractive according to science the  answer might surprise you this website  will do an analysis of your face and  rank how attractive you are not  surprising to anyone coming in five is  chloe she got a 62 percent on the  attractiveness scale surprising to me  coming in four was kylie jenner she got  a 68  on the attractiveness scale another  shock to me coming in three was kim just  above kylie a 69  on the attractiveness scale this  surprised me the most out of all of them  totally thought she'd be number one  kendall number two and 84  on the attractiveness scale and coming  in hot at number one is courtney 89  on the attractiveness scale let me know  do you guys agree disagree